and Chisholm co-author of a book called
Lord Beaverbrook why is a book by this
title of any interest to Americans well
I think anyone who's interested in the
power of the press in the 20th century
should be interested in Lord Beaverbrook
he was a canadian-born press proprietor
and political operator who played a key
part in English journalistic and
political life for the first fifty years
of the century
his American connections were were quite
strong he spent quite a lot of time in
the States he had many many friends
there but above all I suppose they
should be interested because he was at
Churchill's right hand during World War
two and some would say was a a key
figure in winning the Battle of Britain
what did he own what did he own he owned
the Express group at the time he earned
the Daily Express which was the highest
circulation newspaper in the world in
the 1930s and he owned the Sunday
Express and he owned the Evening
Standard
those were his three newspapers one of
the things you write about in the book
is that he lived everywhere had all
kinds of houses were well he um his main
base was a high school directly a big
country house outside London he always
had somewhere in London he kept an
apartment in the Waldorf Astoria in New
York he had a house in the Bahamas he
had a house in Jamaica he had a house in
Canada he had a house in the South of
France so he was some oh and a house and
a farm or two in Somerset
so I think we worked out he had 12 or 13
places to live at one point say he
wasn't short of when did he die he died
in 1964 how old was he when he died 85
so he lived a good long full life how
did he get from Canada to Britain he
left Canada when he was thirty he'd
already made an enormous fortune but not
in newspapers he used to say he spent
his money on his boat
he didn't make his money in newspapers
he made money out of nowhere he was born
the son of a of the manse in Canada and
he made his money out of selling stocks
and bonds and putting mergers together
he was a financier in the boom time in
in in Canada before the first world war
he left Canada and arrived in England in
1910 1911 and never really left I mean
he went backwards and forwards but he
was based in England really from then on
when did he become a lord and where did
he get the name Beaverbrook well he he
used to pretend that he took the name
Beaverbrook from a little mountain
stream in his native New Brunswick where
he used to go and watch the Beavers play
we decided that this was one of a number
of them embroideries that that he used
to like to make about his early life he
was given a peerage at the end of the
first world war by Lloyd George after he
had successfully pulled off a tremendous
political coup one of the great
political coos in British politics which
was to get asked without its prime
minister and Lloyd George in and after
that he was he was made Lord Beaverbrook
as a result given a periods what's that
mean made a member of the House of Lords
he also was elected oh yes he'd been an
MP again it was one of the most
remarkable rapid dramatic rise to
political prominence that I think's ever
happened in this country I mean he
arrived in the earliest summer of 1910
and by Christmas 1911 he was an MP he a
member the house a member of parliament
yes he didn't actually have the vote
when he became a member of parliament in
in Britain in other words he was a
Canadian citizen he was a gradient
citizen could vote in Britain no he
couldn't vote but he could stand for
Parliament and he did become an elected
MP in the winter of 1911 how long did he
stay a member of the House he didn't
really like the House of Commons very
much because he wasn't a natural public
performer in politics he liked to be
behind the scenes
he was an MP until he became a peer so
from 1919 11 until 1916 1917 so five or
six years he was a member of the House
of Commons did you ever meet him no I
never met him my husband did he offered
my husband a job would you tell that
story it's the opening of the book yes
what the story of how husband got into
this in the first place well my husband
was a young journalist working on the
observer English Sunday newspaper and
Beaverbrook was a tremendous talent
spotter
he was obsessively interested in
journalism and and in spotting
journalistic talents and if he saw a
story in any paper that he liked by
somebody he would lift the phone and say
bring that man to see me on I think I'd
like to give him a job so he asked my
called my husband to go and see him in
the South of France and he'd sent in the
ticket and Michel flew out to nice and
was whisked off to the trailer house and
at cap died and spent I think 24 hours
roughly with him observing Beaverbrook
with his hangers on and his women his
servants listening to his table talk
which was quite something and was found
him absolutely fascinating but also
found him quite sinister and at that
time the beaver Brookes newspaper the
Express was not something that her quite
idealistic slightly left-wing young
journalist which my husband was at the
time necessarily wanted to attach
himself to so he decided that he
wouldn't take up the offer and as you
know the book opens with a long account
of this that Michel read at the time
which we used as our starting off point
in the book when did you meet your
husband I met my husband when he gave me
a job on The Observer in the early 1960s
and when did you two decide that this
was worth doing book well there was
obviously room for new biography of Lord
Beaverbrook there was an excellent book
done 20 years ago by the great historian
AJP Taylor but AJP Taylor was a friend
of Beaver Brooks he was to some extent
on Beaver Brooks payroll he contributed
to the
Sunday Express and we felt that here was
a very important figure who never in
fact been written about by somebody who
wasn't on his payroll and you know that
the time had come to to give it a try
it was suggested initially as a book for
my husband and he was still writing a
column on the observer at the time and
obviously you know there was an enormous
amount of work to do so we decided that
the thing to do was to collaborate and
do it together and what did you start it
heavens very long time ago I mean it we
started it in about 1987 1988 and it
took it took pretty much five years with
us both working on it but not for time
we worked on it full-time for about two
years of this only aside
when did you publish it first in the
United Kingdom it was published in
October last year in October 92 and it
was published in in the States in
January of this year is it packaged
differently that here I mean we're in
London but this is a book that we bought
in in the United States is it packaged
differently and how is it what's the
doing the cover is slightly different
the the it's the same picture but it's
designed slightly differently otherwise
the books exactly the same how many
marriages did Lord B River County buta
book was married twice his first
marriage was to a charming sweet natured
Canadian girl who he married early on in
Canada who came to England with him in
1910 they brought up a young family and
so on she died in 1927 and thereafter
well in fact not only thereafter
Beaverbrook had a great many love
affairs but he didn't actually marry
again until shortly before he died when
he married the widow of his old friend
Sir James Dunne who was a great deal
younger than Beaverbrook on who in fact
is still alive and still lives that jerk
Lee the country house in Surrey just
outside London here's a bunch of
pictures of women Barbara Cartland right
down
how do these women figure in his life
well Beaverbrook was very very
interested in women and obviously
attractive to women although he was
small gnome-like
and many people thought him hideously
ugly but he must have had something
Barbara Cartland was one of a number of
young journalists who he spotted and he
gave her advice on how to write in fact
she says to this day that Beaverbrook
taught her to write and since she's had
a most astonishing career written 500
books and made a fortune out of her
writing I mean he was obviously quite
good at encouraging her she was a very
pretty ambitious determined young woman
in the 1920s and he took a fancy to her
beyond that I really don't know you say
that some people values astonishingly
ugly here's a picture on the back of the
book what
what's it were was his where were his
parents from Beaver Brooks parents were
Scottish his father had emigrated from
Scotland to be a Presbyterian minister
in Canada and his mother was a partly
Scottish and partly Northern Irish
extraction but Beaverbrook and all his
brothers and sisters there were eleven
of them they were a huge family we're
all born in in New Brunswick in in
Canada Battle of Britain when did it
happen and what did he have to do with
it you mentioned it earlier
well the Battle of Britain took place in
the summer of of 1940 and really was the
turning point the the moment when it
when the whole course of the Second
World War was in the balance and what
was extraordinary was that Weaver Brook
was a famous of Pisa in the 1930s
Beaverbrook was deeply profoundly
anti-war he'd been in the First World
War and he had seen such suffering and
such incompetence and such misery that
he remained completely committed to
keeping Britain out of European war
and he maintained that position although
he was a great friend of Churchill's
from their early manhood he maintained
that position even after the Second
World War began but nevertheless when
Churchill took over from Chamberlain in
May of 1940 the one man he felt he must
have at his right hand was was
Beaverbrook and Beaverbrook switched
overnight more or less from trying to
end the war and bring about peace he
went on operating like that even after
the war had started he switched the
minute Churchill took over and he became
no Churchill's a key person in
Churchill's attempt to to to win the war
and Churchill made him minister of
aircraft production which meant that he
was in charge of producing the planes to
fight off the German onslaught and that
is what he did with immense energy and
brilliance it was as much a propaganda
victory for Eva Brooke as it was
anything else you know when you read the
history and here's a picture of Lord
Beaverbrook and Winston Churchill and
inside the book right here sitting on a
couch mr. Churchill was both a
conservative and a liberal I remember
the party what was he he crossed the
flow of the house as they say he started
as a conservative and then he became a
liberal and then he became a
conservative again Churchill was
considered a maverick for a long time in
British politics he was considered
unsound and eccentric and domineering
and aggressive and you know his
political career went through many very
very low patches what about Lord Byron
well Beaverbrook Beaverbrook in politics
was somebody who needed a he needed
someone to admire someone to promote he
really got his way but found his way to
thee to the heart of British politics
through a fellow Canadian Andrew bond
allure who was briefly conservative
prime minister in the early 1920s
Bonnell or died not long after he became
prime minister which was a great
personal tragedy for Beaverbrook and
also changed his whole position in
relation to public life Churchill he and
Churchill were very close they also had
many tremendous battles and
disagreements not least in the 1930s
over what should be done about the rise
of fascism but I mean beaver Brooks role
with relationship with Churchill is I
think one of the most fascinating and
important things about his life story
and it's even after five or six years
work I wouldn't altogether pretend to
understand it but Churchill needed him
in some way he he said himself I needed
his vitality I needed his energy
Beaverbrook was one of those characters
who can convey energy and confidence to
other people this picture inside the
book you know what year how old was he
in this picture that is a picture of
Beaverbrook in Somerset in on a tour of
inspection of one of his farms and I
would say he was then in his late 70s
where did you find the most valuable
information that and my by the way how
much of this is new never been published
well quite a lot of the material in that
book is is new in that although it was
available to AJP Taylor he didn't choose
to use it in quite the way we've used it
the Beaverbrook
archive is a few hundred yards from
where we're sitting it is in the House
of Lords at Westminster and there are
nine hundred boxes of papers of Lord
Beaverbrook there mostly of his public
life but some of his private and
financial and family papers as well
there are also papers in in Canada at
the University of New Brunswick and most
of our work was done right here sitting
in the House of Lords going through box
after box after box we also went to
Canada to look into the papers there
there's another picture of him sitting
in a chair you know where
is that's his study Kirkley his country
house outside London and he's got his
famous sound scriber by his side he
loved gadgets beetle Brook and he used
to bombard his editors with instructions
that were it was like it was an early
form of tape recorder he used to talk
into the science scriber and the sound
scriber and then these little messages
would be typed up and sprayed out to his
editors wherever they happened to be he
was a very very hands-on proprietor new
editor of Beaver Brooks could ever ever
begin to pretend that he was not
interfered with by thee by the owner
who's in this picture with him here that
is the second lady Beaverbrook i think
that is not long before Beaverbrook died
she she is the lady Beaverbrook who
still lives at raptly did the family
cooperate with you at all the family
gave us every access and and a certain
amount of help some of the family were
quite involved with the book for
instance beaver Brooks granddaughter
lady Jean Campbell who was briefly
married to Norman Mailer and lived in
New York for many years as a
correspondent for The Evening Standard
she was beaver Brooks favorite
grandchild his oldest grandchild and she
gave us a great deal of help some of the
family preferred not to be particularly
involved but they were in every way a
cooperative and helpful to us
did he use his newspapers politically he
certainly did that was the point of them
as far as he was concerned he said after
the war when there was a British inquiry
into the the the power of the press and
knew whether that was undue press
influence in politics Beaverbrook took
the wind out over everybody sails by
just admitting it from the start he said
I run my newspapers for purposes of
propaganda he'd see he that that was the
whole point as far as he was concerned
did he leave a legacy here in Britain
well one of the extraordinary and other
poignant things is that in fact in terms
of express newspapers he didn't leave
them in a very strong position and they
declined fairly dramatically after after
his death
still here yes I only express the Daily
Express and the Sunday Express in the
Evening Standard still exists they're
still well-known papers in Britain but
they they are owned by a the Express
group which is simply a large media
group with no connection with with the
Beaverbrook or Aitken families but they
they are a shadow of what they were in
his day there's no doubt about it I mean
the Express was in the 20s and 30s the
most successful newspaper in the world
and Chisholm you're married to a man who
is you're by the name of Michael Davey
who is also a journalist that tell us
about the two of you where were you born
I was born in London in 1940 just around
the time that Beaverbrook was winning
the Battle of Britain where'd you go to
school I went to a girls boarding school
in Dorset and then I went to Oxford
University where I read history when did
you decide you want to be a journalist I
got involved in journalism apps at
university I did quite a lot of student
journalism and then a group of friends
of mine started a magazine called
Private Eye which still operates in
London which is a satirical magazine and
I worked my first job was on Private Eye
and that gave me a taste for for
journalism and it seems to have stuck
with me but I've also worked in
publishing and I've I worked on a new on
newspapers for a few years but compared
to my husband who was a been a
journalist taught his working life I've
chopped and changed and written books
and worked in publishing as well where's
your husband from he is English he was
also he also studied history at Oxford
he spent most of his career on the
observer which is a Sunday newspaper
we've also both of us lived and worked
in the United States and also in
Australia where'd you work in the United
States I worked in New York on Time
magazine for two years in the early 60s
as a researcher
and Michael has spent many months in in
Washington writing from Washington for
for the observer we both lived in
Washington in the early 70s during the
Watergate period he was covering that
for the observer we have a series of
pictures announcer Mike get him while
I'm getting I'll ask you about the fact
that where were these taken there there
look like they're all from the same
series oh yes now that that was
Beaverbrook I just want to make sure
it's the right election campaign it was
an election campaign at the end of the
war he is making a political speech
would you find the pictures I think that
Cirie's came from the Express archive
the Express still has a huge archive of
Beaverbrook evil Brooke material you say
in here that he had a close relationship
with King Edward the eighth who
abdicated yes what was the relationship
and what impact we have on the
abdication
well Beaverbrook masterminded the
attempt which succeeded for many many
months to keep all word of what was
going on between the king and mrs.
Simpson out of the British press
Beaverbrook along with other newspaper
editors went to the palace and agreed
that this was not a suitable subject for
the the readers of the newspapers to to
to have I mean it was an extraordinary
situation in that of course in the
States and also in Europe journalists
were writing the story and printing
pictures of of the king and and his
mistress together and speculating about
what was going to happen for months and
months but the British public were were
not informed of course there were masses
of rumors and endless gossip and people
knew really what was going on but but
Beaverbrook himself would never
particularly been a monarchist until
that point he rather fell for the young
king
he felt a kind of sympathy for his
problems and his hopeless love affair
Beaverbrook had a very soft spot for
people in trouble he could be very tough
cruel and manipulative but he could also
be very kind and human and unsupportive
of people going through a crisis and I
think he felt I think he felt sorry for
the king when you were finished with
this book did you conclude about what
you would think of him if you had a
chance to know him well one who you
always wonder that because you spend
five or six years of your life
obsessively interested in in somebody
who you've never met and I think it
would have been hard to resist evil
books trauma I think I don't see him
either as a great hero always a great
villain people said to us quite a number
of people said to us when we were
working on the book how can you bear to
work on the story of such a evil
manipulative devious destructive figure
people did think some people did think
he was a very sinister figure and a
corrupting figure in British public life
I don't think that I think he had great
charm and and some marvelous qualities
and I think he was a great newspaperman
how would he get along with people like
the late Robert Maxwell or Rupert
Murdoch well I think I mean Maxwell was
a crook now there were rumors that that
Beaverbrook was a bit of a crook in his
youth in fact he was nicknamed [ __ ]
crook by English high society when he
first started to operate in English high
society he was always to some extent an
outsider and you know the English rather
liked to be able to put rich Outsiders
who come in and try and take over our
politics our newspapers our lives they
quite like to and put them in their
place but I think I I think
compared to Maxwell he was an honest man
compared to Murdock
I think Murdock seems to me I'm no
expert on Rupert Murdock but it seems to
me he is not as interested as much
interested in journalism and politics as
he is in in profits and power there's a
picture of a famous writer Rudyard
Kipling yes in this picture that the
audience will see I believe he's
standing what was their relationship
this is Lord Beaverbrook there that is a
picture of Kipling supporting
Beaverbrook in his election campaign in
1911 when he was standing as a member of
parliament it was a great triumph for
the young Canadian to be able to field
in his campaign this immensely revered
and distinguished writer Rudyard Kipling
the great writer and poet of the Empire
Kipling's relationship with Beaverbrook
slightly shocked me I decided maybe I
was more prudish than I'd realized
Beaverbrook especially early in his
career he used his money to draw people
into his net which I mean is not a new
thing it's happened before and it'll
happen again but with Kipling he he
handled his investments he made him
substantial presence of money
he was also immensely in or of Kipling
and because beaver Brooks great passion
was the was the Empire he found in
Kipling someone who he could he could
greatly admire that the financial
connections helped him if you could go
back in this book and to the period
which you were the most fascinated hmm
in which which area would be what time
very well the period that I found most
interesting was when Beaverbrook was
running the Express in the late twenties
early thirties and he was involved with
some of the most interesting writers of
the period I I found his his
relationship with Rebecca West
and with William Joe Hardy but who were
both writers who he fascinated and used
in various ways and who then in their
turn wrote about him in their novels I
found that personally very interesting I
was I was also fascinated by the the
early political story it taught me a
very great deal about how English
political life operated then how did the
book do or how is it doing in Great
Britain and how is it doing in the
United States well I it got very very
nice and flattering coverage in in the
press here and also some very nice
reviews in the States
it's it has sold reasonably well here I
don't know how it's been selling in the
States but but it's about to come out in
paperback here and I think the
publishers have reasonably reasonably
happy with the way it's gone got another
book ready to write we've got one or two
ideas but nothing ready to ready to talk
about this is what the book looks like
and it's the life of Lord Beaverbrook
journalist Member of Parliament also a
member the House of Lords and our guest
has been and Chisholm who is the
co-author of this book with her husband
Michael Davey thank you very much for
joining us thank you